you never went to acting school or
anything like that you didn't do any of
the traditional kind of moves you just
started acting when you were a kid right
you just went into it it just sort of
came came
certain parts of it came easily to me
you know i mean i like i remember the
feeling on a stage and being like why
does this feel comfortable all the other
kids are pissing their pants and i'm
like this feels natural it's crazy that
you felt that comfortable and and the
the high school play was uh fiddler on
the roof right i was cast and fiddler on
the roof in the senior year of high
school right and then i got this movie
october sky and then i couldn't play
tevye and then i went and did this movie
instead it's one of the biggest regrets
in my career i gotta say
really
heavier in the role tevie is the role
do you love me
do i what
do you love me
yes yes
do i love you
do i what
do i love you
after 25 years
i've washed your clothes
[Laughter]
what was that famous story about that
first movie you did october sky that you
got into an argument with your your with
chris cooper and that um
chris stopped you and told you how to be
a better listener every actor loves to
pretend like you know they're tough and
then
also you know they also love just
screaming and yelling you know it's the
final opportunity to get that out like
that's acting you know
and so i was doing it and i thought take
after take i was like oh i'm killing
this like i'm just screaming and yelling
and chris is a very quiet composed man
very measured very thoughtful talk about
preparation
and he comes up to me and he goes i
don't know what you're doing
you're just yelling at me
just listen to what i'm saying to you
wow were you devastated
i was what was great about it was yes
and i was already in the scene i was
devastated so i was like
oh my heart just went oh god i've just i
feel so embarrassed what am i oh what am
i doing
and then i just
took the opportunity to not fill it with
all this acting you know not like i'm
listening to you i just listened and
then as they talked it really started to
piss me off
like what he was saying started pissed
me off and then
i was like oh my god i was riding a real
wave and then i went
and that was the biggest gift he i mean
an actor's ever given me honestly